I'm gonna go really fast through a lot
of content
so hopefully that forces some questions
out of you what I like to do is I put
took some bullet points off of the
vendors websites that's great right you
can read them I'm going to talk about
like how do you use them practically
either as data scientist or as just any
kind of consumer of web technologies
last questions at the end I'm so
basically elasticsearch what I typically
use it for is to full cert full-text
search
primarily and grabbing data from either
logs or systems or sometimes one time I
had scraped data from a ticketing system
to do some really basic metrics over
periods of time for the use cases we're
gonna go over today we're going to
scrape some web content throw them into
elasticsearch search over that and then
the other example is going to be using
github api grabbing data from its api is
doing something with it sorting it an
elastic search and in showing some of
those results in Kabana infra-red us as
you can see there's a lot of features
that has typically what we're gonna do
is we're gonna get some key values
stored them in Redis we are going to
also get a dictionary and set it into a
hash we're also gonna I'm going to show
you a good practical use for the list
data data structure and within Redis and
kind of talk about other things you can
use it for if it's persistent and those
types of things for the demo we're going
to basically do very similar to elastic
search but putting that data into Redis
and then the final demo will basically
show you taking data out of it and
rendering it in a dashboard just getting
some basic survey stats and then also
putting data into keen IO and showing
that also using Google chart
so for the first example ultimately what
I'm going to do is I'm going to scrape a
list of websites that I've listed here
I'm going to connect to elasticsearch
I'm going to basically strip out all of
the HTML tags and other kind of data
that I don't want like links or
something other than that and then
eventually I'm going to create a JSON
blob and then throw it into
elasticsearch so ultimately what I'll do
here is I'll run the script so you can
see exactly what's happening
so I'm scraping the content putting in
the JSON so I hit several websites you
can see here this is some of this is my
personal website with NPR Google News
and I'm using beautifulsoup for that ps4
version 4 and like I mentioned stripping
out all the HTML tags creating the JSON
and then storing it to elasticsearch and
we could see the output here now this is
for basically if you want to do
full-text search so if there is any type
of data this was an example using you
know obviously on websites but you could
store any d and elastic search and
search over it this is probably the
easiest to show you because I'm sure
somebody in here is at least at least
half I would hope half the room Apps
Script website are got data from
websites or from github or from some
other API source and store it and want
to store it somewhere other than just
your laptop or just doing quick analysis
using pandas or something and how to
kind of view those results in the
project that I've listed for on the
front of my thing my github repo I'll
show you at the end I'm just going to
basically run a simple angular site to
show you the results in a full-text
search mode
so one of the sites was some news and my
own personal website so if I were to
type in something like Trump I'm sure
some result will show up if I were to
type in music or marshy ski for an exact
result the results get rendered in HTML
using angular's elasticsearch plugin so
this was basically demonstrate scraping
web content doing something with that
whipped on twitch was removing HTML tags
and putting it into elasticsearch and
then seeing those results in a full text
search kind of way and all of this stuff
that's shown here in this project is
going to be listed in this repository at
my github so I'm going to show you
something very similar but this time
instead of actually using beautifulsoup
we're just gonna hit an API using
pythons request library so just like
that when we connect to elasticsearch we
create our index which I'll talk a
little bit more at the end making the
request so I'm just gonna basically get
a return from github based on a search
of users named Tim or Tim somewhere in
their name and then actually making the
request and what that and what this
requests are what this response from the
API is going to look like is something
like this we're basically going to get a
count of around 30 users back in the
items array we're gonna iterate over
that over those items and we're going to
take out their login name and then we're
gonna hit another github API to take all
the repo data and say hey what's their
favorite language that they use and one
of those repos responses will look
something like this where we say a
particular user show me all of your
repos and we're going to have a field in
here called language
I'm basically gonna do a max of all the
languages and tell me what's their
favorite language of a particular person
so I'm gonna create a just a list of
people that we got from the log in JSON
response and then we're gonna iterate
over that list and go and fetch all
their repositories on github using a
request a request or a get request and
then we're gonna add languages to yet
another list and then we're going to get
their favorite language we're gonna
create JSON or a dictionary and then
eventually we're gonna convert that to
JSON and post it to to elasticsearch in
this particular string elasticsearch
will have your main index where you want
to store data your type which in this
case we're just gonna call people and
then ID would be typically a unique
identifier or an identifier for a
particular person in this case so how
we're storing data is we're kind of
segmenting our data via our index and
then within the index you can have
multiple types and then within one type
you can have multiple IDs so in this
case we have github as the index the
type will be people because we can have
people we can have repos we can have
languages we can have pull requests we
can have all kinds of other types and in
the IDs essentially is for that
particular person or it could be a repo
name it could be a random string of
numbers anything that means something to
you and then since we're already using
the elasticsearch library in python you
could do something very similar via
requests but since there's already
library just consumed it and what this
one will look like is
so basically right now it's going and
when it says created true means they
actually created an elastic search
there's no failures and this is for
every user that we've pulled from the
user lift from github and then we went
to their repos and then said hey give me
the max of all their languages and that
will tell you their favorite language
now now obvious I'm showing you get hub
data this can be any data that you want
it to be it was just that it was just
easy because it's a public API I could
have done stuff with you know a data set
I could have script web content I could
have generated Mach data as long as it
goes into JSON format you can post it to
elastic search into your index type in
your ID
Kabana is it's a data visualization
dashboarding tool looks very similar to
tableau or you know if you were gonna
build your own obviously use d3 or
something along those lines when you're
setting up Kabana you have to define the
index and what you want it to get data
from and it shows me all of the fields
that were indexed which the only ones
that we indexed for this particular one
was language their favorite the person's
favorite language and the user ID or the
name of the particular user and now
since it's stored in cabana we can do we
could build data visualizations based on
any of the data that we put in here
and just to show you this was the raw
JSON request body that we had sent so it
was just he was name value was TCR
language was the key and then the value
is JavaScript this is just the metadata
with elasticsearch you could do scoring
and there's some other metadata fields
that you can add I think even if I'm not
mistaken I think you can even do like
geolocation would be under metadata if
I'm not mistaken
I'm just gonna show you a quick
dashboard and run through like setting
up one visualization to show you kind of
what it looks like it does it's
intimidating at first set visualizations
in Cabana but then I have to get the
hang of it
it's pretty simple
so some of the visual visualizations
that we see here is just a regular data
table showing you a list of names in
their favorite language and we see a pie
chart telling us that JavaScript out of
the users that we took from that
JavaScript was the primary favorite
language then Python and then Ruby and
other languages that are listed here
there's some other visualizations I'll
kind of show you that we have a count of
the total of people that we indexed we
have unique count of languages so there
was out of those 30 users we only have
10 unique languages that we pulled from
and when you create these dashboards you
can also save them and create your own
widgets you can create unique search
patterns like for example if I were to
type in Python we could see all the
Python users and just get a count we can
also see this being a being manipulated
or I could just say click on JavaScript
it'll render all the JavaScript data
within Kabana now once you start storing
like a date/time stamp - with JSON field
and you index it as a date you can start
doing creating graphs and things over a
period of time so if you're going to
archive how many subscribers joined your
service or if you're going to do
analysis over time and you win the store
it here you can see times up to a year
or custom custom time ranges you can
also do some drag-and-drop to say hey I
want to see in a particular time range
data and you can get deeper and deeper
into it so I like to use this as a tool
when working with other api's or other
things out that I'm pulling from other
sources as a way to kind of visualize it
without having to have much knowledge of
doing data visualizations and such
I'm going to do a very similar example
using Redis so Redis what I like to use
a for and a lot of people use it for is
caching certain types of data structures
I even use it sometimes as my main data
source for a prototype app and building
or I just kind of want to store
something there to keep off to the side
that's going to be there later when I
work on something and in Python there's
already a library I mean just do Pippin
saw Redis you connect to Redis the same
examples before is we're going to
iterate over users repository or all the
repos that they have and get their
favorite language very similar example
like we did for elastic search we're not
doing multiple users but you know it
still would work in this use case but I
just wanted to show a really basic
example showing you storing data in
elastic search and storing it in Redis
we do the same thing here in iterating
over our Doosan array putting into a
list getting the max count or the most
utilized language for a particular user
for set we're just gonna set the key
value so the key would be language or
Lang in this case and language would be
the favorite language if you build some
sort of dictionary you would set it in
your hash map and that would be hm set
would be the command operation you would
do in Redis and then retrieving a value
from a key would just be get and if you
wanted to get all of the key value pairs
in your hash map you would just do it H
get all so with this example looks like
it's like I said very similar to what we
did for elasticsearch before Redis so
just kind of showing you interchangeable
like what this particular technology
looks like and then working with
rightists because they all have their
place rights like I mentioned before
full-text search or you want to do you
want to just store data and then build
visualizations at Cabana and like I said
that could be anything from system logs
to system data it could be like Internet
of Things type of stuff any kind of data
you want it could be analysis you do
locally and you want to just post it
somewhere so you can keep track of it
over a period of time and for Redis I'll
show you even a better example pulling
this in through a web interface to build
sort of dashboards let's kind of show
you what that could look like again
now I'm going to show you more advanced
example using Redis and I'm using flask
also and also Kineo to store information
so I'm using Redis and Keene and flask
to basically take input from user then
storing that and then showing you
different examples on what you can use
Redis for and even for Keene i/o so I
built this really quick survey app just
to show you like users importing data
and then what happens and how I built it
using Redis so this is the dashboard
that I built out basically I wanted to
show overall customer satisfaction over
all customers dislike or like I wanted
to show things for a period of time like
today or a week or monthly I wanted to
show a list of recent items that were
appended to a list in Redis build out
some Kineo
google charts which I'll kind of go over
that quickly and then basically just
ultimately counts over periods of time
so in this particular app like let's say
I dislike something so when I hit like
or dislike or the smiley face or frown
face what's gonna happen is that I'm
going to create I'm gonna increment on a
key and it starts at zero so what's
gonna happen is I'm gonna dislike my
total dislikes my daily dislikes my
weekly dislikes on my monthly dislikes
and those are all separate keys and the
reason why I increment them in Redis
like that is because I can flush out the
cash at those periods of time so I can
say hey on Sunday flush out all my
weekly tees and start over at the end of
the month flush out my monthly keys and
start over incrementing from 0 so far to
show you here and I dislike management
and i refresh the dashboard you can see
my overall customer satisfaction is sad
overall customer dislike as management
you can see my top dislike for today
this week this month since I have no
data for a month obviously you just see
that this will populate and it over a
month period of time if things happen
during the week you can see that I
create a list of recent dislikes so this
way let's say you are a manager or
you're a store owner or something you
can be like okay well I want to see what
people recently disliked and you can
store that in a Redis list and Keane
basically you can use Google charts to
pull King data in they have great if
great dashboard examples already on
their github I'll show you that link and
you can see my total count for dislikes
is one and my told dislike count for
management is one so what this code kind
of look like I'm just gonna do another
example for like and service
so what this code looks like is
basically that create a flask web app
I'm importing the Keens client library
and basically I have my my project key
my right key I'm connecting to Redis
also I basically wrote a function to
tell me that if my list is greater than
10 then push out the right element of my
list as the last like my oldest element
in my list because you have a left push
and a right push I've did left as in
your as first in this particular one and
the farthest right would be the oldest
so I'm basically saying hey get all the
data out of Redis if the length is
greater than 10 then pop out the last
element on the right
same thing for dislike as I mentioned
before get is getting the key the key
value pair are just the value in this
case of this like daily dislike weekly
dislike monthly dislike and you can use
something like ap scheduler which is a
Python library to do scheduling of
certain types of tasks you can set
explorations on keys so you could say oh
this key expires after so much period of
time in this case I wanted to keep it
more scheduled to say that Sunday at 5
a.m. or Monday at 5 a.m. I want this to
flush you would just flush out that key
or that certain types of sets
I'll range just retrieves the range of
the list and I'm also doing maxes on on
my other elements and then you can see
that incrementing the values of like my
daily likes my weekly likes so that was
pretty much it for this particular
example but you can see using storing
data in Redis or elasticsearch how this
can kind of help you out from either a
workflow perspective or prototyping or
just storing some sort of data for the
short or long term then just in your
computer's current memory
so is there any questions I'll start
taking questions now yep Oh for these
visualizations I could have used like
another technology but I kind of wanted
to demonstrate using very similar
technologies like they're not like
similar in the regards of like oh I'm
gonna use this for this X thing it's
like you take some sort of dictionary or
key or value and you store it into these
data sources and it looks very similar
and retrieving it looks also very
similar right you're just basically
doing puts or posts and gets so the
operations or methods are pretty much
the same so but keen and this point is
doing all these types of graphs you
could do pie charts you can do other
types of things the repository is on
their github called keen dashboards and
basically they already kind of built out
some of the google charts JavaScript
stuff so basically all you have to do is
just give it your reader key in your
project key and it will go fetch data
from Keene and if you don't know what
Keene is it's just a
software-as-a-service right that sits
out there and it takes in any sort of
data and then you can do things make
queries over that data so they're
through their web SAS offering or you
can obviously build your own dashboards
what I really liked about Keene is there
or any of these technologies is that you
can start building out any sort of
visual analytics to your customer it's
like not just like to management but
like if you wanted to walk into a store
and show that what people are most
reached recently purchasing like what's
their favorite food on the item or
what's their favorite yogurt it kind of
gives you that ability to kind of build
quick dashboards to show customers
information or it could be internal
dashboards to doesn't have to be
customer facing but I really like Keene
for that for that aspect and of course
they handle everything for you
know so these are two separate sotapanna
is hosted locally on my laptop I'm
actually running it in a docker
container I'm running elasticsearch
coupon and write us all my da container
so this is all locally hosted so good
solution for like if you're working in
the enterprise or like you're showing a
mom-and-pop store like you know some
basic data and you don't want to build
out all to HTML and JavaScript stuff
it's really easy to just put data in
elasticsearch build that visualizations
you can give them a link you can set
basic off type of things with nginx but
yes oakiness
purely hosted like they host all that as
a solution and in Cabana just talks to
your elasticsearch instance and pulls
the index that you define that I went
through in that one screen is answer
your question cool yeah
I'm out
I kind of don't really be that want to
be that guy but like I would just never
use [ __ ] but uh but really like if you
just want to build something that's not
going to be like amazon.com scalable or
anything right just store JSON blob into
a collection right and do things like
that you could do very similar in [ __ ]
to it's all kind of the same the JSON
store document store
alas yeah just because it's easy to get
started its schema list so like you'll
have to find schemas and go talk about
like relationships your data you can
kind of pivot early on in your data
model essentially so it's very powerful
if you're a startup or you're a quick
project and you're getting off the
ground and you don't have a lot of users
and you don't want to worry about like
those things I mentioned with typical
sequel databases you would use [ __ ] and
I'm guilty I've used [ __ ] before in the
past I do like it just obviously after a
certain part sharding gets really
difficult and other things it depends on
the use cases right so if you're
building like a typical like type of
website yeah you probably use [ __ ] for
that bright but if you're building like
search you would want to use elastic
search for that and and and another
things too like if you wanted to show
proximity searches like based on people
coming in right elastic search has that
built in there's a lot of other cool
features elastic search has built in but
I would primarily use it for full-text
search or you wanna store data and
visualize in Cabana you could actually
create an API that sits in front of
elastic search to strip out the metadata
fields and just show the rich oh the
body that was stored in there you can do
that too
I've never seen anybody do that but I
think I did it one time when I was
keeping an inventory a lot of inventory
of a lot of stuff and I didn't want to
deal with [ __ ] so I put everything in
elastic search and then I basically made
a unique query to a lass of search to
return this particular item
search in an inventory and then
basically strip out the metadata of that
header field that you saw there it was
attached to the JSON blob and then just
returned it out so you could do stuff
like that to I just never really hear
people talking about like doing that it
was just pretty quick for me just get
that going I could have used Mangla too
for that also any other questions
yeah oh I actually didn't do that the
WebSocket portion I said I just kind of
replaced Keene but ultimately that flask
apps that I showed you I'm gonna commit
it on github I didn't keep it in there
because I didn't feel like exporting my
secret keys essentially to my
environment but I was planning on coming
into at same exact repo that I showed
you but as of right now all the scripts
and things called Kalka was like just a
angular front-end for elastic search
that's all in that repository but I was
gonna add this last product I showed you
in there so you could see more in detail
exactly how I'm determining if customers
are happy or sad or top items or daily
things or the list of most recent likes
or dislikes yep yeah
any more questions yep okay yeah
so basically you could do all types of
things but like if you're working with
Python and you have either key value
pairs or dictionaries or tuples or other
things and let's say let's say they only
live during your script is running and
like you're happy with that then maybe
you don't want to store it an idea to
store but like let's say if you want to
store things in there to either be
rendered over WebSockets or you want to
build your own dashboard or you want to
have it just sit there for like long
term use you would just build out a key
like let's say call it a long term
analyst one or something and then you
can store data in there and you can do
long term analyst too and then you can
store you know dictionary in that
hashmap so here's all the commands that
you can run so you can do increment the
integer of a hash filled by a given
number H get all which shows you get all
the key value pairs in that hash you can
say Helen only give me the value of a
key in a hash or a dictionary in this
case so basically just like storing data
there for like shorter long term like
whether you're going to do things over a
period of time or a short time or if you
wanted to do like a web example like I
showed you where you can kind of build a
dashboard of some of the some of the
data that you would wrangle and you want
to kind of show that in a web view those
would be like typical use cases you can
also do like like for example when you
go like to pinterest.com
I don't know if it's still there anymore
but like days to tell you like top items
that like sold or like our most recent
things that happened right as almost
like a stream you can put that in a
Redis list right just a list of elements
and just say hey show me top ten lit
like the top ten latest entries in my
list from left to right or from right to
left so you could store all that and
write us so if you had a script that
wanted to live longer in life and not
just like run like run it and then it
does something and then you see the
results and that's great but you want to
store it for whatever a particular
reason you can use rightists or elastic
search or [ __ ] or any kind of data
store
at first it's written into memory and
then it persists after you can see you
can always configure this but after so
much time I think it's like maybe minute
at most it would persist the disks to a
flat file in Redis you could set it to
be completely memory cache if you just
really didn't care about your data but
like if you cared you can have it
persist like immediately you can have it
do like batch persist on disk in batch
mode those are all options of Redis
there's a lot things that playing the
part right whether Redis is local or if
there's a cluster and how it basically
writes to different nodes the
performance of them I don't I can't
speak to redshift but we're just Redis
is pretty fast I mean it's it's really
fast I don't know what the numbers are
but you like you said if you want it to
be even faster you can write things to
disk in batch mode but then you might
have a loss of data or if you just
persist immediately to disk and this way
it's always there
lasted skirts get skills pretty well so
it's really matter up to your cluster
reyes skills also very well but
ultimately it determines on the memory
of your system that you have rats
installed on so like for example it
doesn't make sense the store six key
value pairs
instead of just one dictionary into a
hash map you would save more memory by
doing that right but like what that
equates to when it does key value pair
or a hash map with that memory footprint
is I'm not 100% sure we got five more
minutes for questions anybody have any
questions
so the Amazon has elastic cache you can
just spin up a rightist node a lot of
people in the past use memcache
I like Redis better so Amazon has a
service I think Redis has their own
Redis cloud that you can sit upright as
nodes on of course you can run docker
like I ran you can just install it
through your assistance package manager
also but yeah those are different things
I think even if Heroku has things that
you can do in digital or Suns droplets
for Redis
all right no more questions and we're
done